Damn, Angelyne, it's so big.
I bet people will talk about
this a hundred years from now.
Oh, oh my God.
It’s working.
Since I was a girl, I've known
that fame is my destiny.
Huge, gigantic fame.
And so I said, “I'm going to
get the love of the world.”
Billboards are popping
up around the city
featuring the striking image
of a blonde with a single name.
Angelyne.
The billboard queen?  Uhhh.
Yes.
But it can be hard
when you become famous.
A lot of people
want to be a part of it
no matter what it takes.
So they'll say and write
just about anything.
She was the devil in disguise.
My dad paid for those.
Money is her bottom line,
not people.
I'd love to be like Barbie.
She won't cry, she doesn't hurt.
You're crazy!  I'm done!
Contrary to what people think...
I'm actually very private
and people should respect that.
Everybody wanted to know,
who is this woman?
You'd look up in the sky
and there she was.
This whole Angelyne story
starts with me.
That did not happen.
He's completely delusional.
When Angelyne showed up,
LA needed her.
Who is the real Angelyne?
Don't you like the not knowing?
I remember that so differently.
Hm, hm, ha.
I’m something that you
have to experience.
Ha.
Oohh.
I'm an innocent little doll.
Oooh.
Boom.
Or a porn star.
Ooooo.
I’m whatever
you want me to be.
But I do not want to be famous
for something that I do,
I want to be famous
for who I am.
I am Angelyne.
Angelyne, no, no, no!
And that's the only
story you need to know.